selon m
bonsoir robot retrouver pour ce
tout nouveau statut peu
désorienté
voici les titres
le déploiement de la fibre
optique dans les tribunes la
franchir un nouveau cap pour
l'opérateur tdf a été
désigné pour mener à bien le
projet
les explications avec m anne
développa avec des rebelles
membres de l'onu ont été tués
par un adulte
professeur de mathématiques au
collège alexandre dumas de
maurepas nous verrons avec elle
commence bien préparé les
enfants durant l'été à la
rochelle scolaires
le déploiement de la fibre
optique dans les tribunes à
profit une nouvelle étape
l'opérateur tdf a été
désigné pour mener à bien le
projet
les explications avec eux à la
télé le pas avec le
vice-président elle ne mérite
pas
d'ici à 2020 les émissions
globales d une ligne devrait
bénéficier du très haut
débit
et cela sans aucune dépense
publique pour en parler nous
accueillons anonyme le palais
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
vice-présidente du numérique
cette étape structurante
alae-eddine numérique est un
établissement public qui a
été créé l'année dernière
en 2016 la volonté du
département
dépecé en fait le bloc
communal communes et les
intercommunalités pour 100
euros projets qui étaient
portés jusque là uniquement
pour le département
de de déployer les ailes d'air
le très haut débit dans les
territoires des victimes
alors le 30 juin dernier la
vente du réseau fibre optique
de l'opérateur free est votée
au conseil départemental
des luttes locales pour la
collectivité il ya eu par trois
depuis 8 millions d'euros
alors pourquoi le conseil
départemental à un beau but le
réseau de fibre optique
hier le comité départemental a
vendu le réseau
professionnels elle s'est
engagée à vendre le réseau
professionnel il serait l'homme
le cancer n'est pas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les particuliers qui
font le typhon finalement
l'objet d'émissions l'émission
de nouvelles cartes de débit
marchal et tdf
anne est écrit ceci permettra
à chrysler de 7 8 et surtout
les infrastructures existantes
pour redéployer de manière
plus efficace et plus rapide
pour eux le très haut débit a
vu ses ventes comme des
particuliers des territoires
ruraux des équipes
or rappelle-t-il est en fait un
opérateur
pour être un opérateur public
privé alors qui est privé mais
c'est à la lumière des
montages de pdm avec notre
c'est-à-dire que tdf mettra par
la suite
à disposition ces
infrastructures aux opérateurs
lauréats est le premier sur le
marché
qui commercialiseront lors de la
frappe par la suite auprès des
particuliers mais pas trop quoi
le rôle de pdm
d'ici à 2020 alors qu'eden
hazard 2 construire les
infrastructures pétrolières
ufip j'ai bien aimé les films
dans lesquels se trouvent
tron transmis ses informations
toute la partie technique toute
la partie génie civile pour
permettre d'amener latino
optique chez les usagers tout en
respectant le planning qui a
déterré défini
bien entendu récemment par le
département
comment la commune département
qui est hermétique or un projet
sur lequel vous travaillez le
numérique avec le conseil
départemental tout à fait et
pourquoi vous avez choisi pour
le tennis
on ne l'a vu le département et
du numérique concours lancé
une consultation sur cette
consultation
3 à 3 on pense
tout à fait indigne d'une
qualité remarquable
en e3 réponse qui était
vraiment attirant pisté de
manière un peu tout à fait
satisfaisante longtemps des
critères qui avaient été
imposées par les villes
numériques et pour cent et
maintenant le choix techniques
il s'est avéré que tdf année
proposer des solutions quitter
légèrement au dessus des
autres
haïti sujet qui nous permettait
et surtout
comme l'avait indiqué tout à
l'heure dominique etienne dépt
cette économie substantielle
au département mais également
à tous les financeurs de ce
projet c'est-à-dire l'état la
région erreur
et du bloc communal et
intercommunalités
c'est à l'opérateur tdf
pouvoir financer sur fonds
propres
en tête le projet
ceux qui étudient dans le
département hausse du cac 40
collectivités du département
des mines les nouveaux hôtels
à économiser alors le projet
était initialement chiffrée à
130 millions d'euros
et puis il ya eu quelques
déménagements dans les années
à 2015 2016 qui ont permis de
revoir légèrement à la baisse
les chiffrages % aujourd hui l
économie réelle
plus concret du département sur
un an
sur cette opération 110
millions d'euros
% et donc d'argent public
cette intercommunalité
département région il est tard
alors que justin est aussi que
vous êtes
première adjointe
sarah la commune deux choix au
cebit
vous êtes aussi jeudi le
président de la communauté de
communes de la prod va les
sauver donc vous êtes
directement concerné par le
très haut débit puisque vous
êtes dans le coin zones
blanches les communes un peu
rurales du sud de libreville
pour le calmer la situation
actuelle notamment dans le
comique la savoureuse
claire dans les communes dans la
commune de chambre des communes
alentour les situations qui ont
été disparates
et dépendent essentiellement de
notre localisation géographique
et de dede de longueur de fil de
cuivre aujourd'hui
elle ne peut en dire autant
d'endroits où ce qui manque
c'est un gros problème dans nos
zones blanches
aussi bien à eux interne que le
crime ne paie que le mobile
et donc tête cette solution va
même permettre d'arriver à
très court terme on est dans le
vide
dans une situation de confort
pour beaucoup plus appréciable
peu de temps pour l'activité
économique et même pour les
particuliers concrètes
concrètement tout acte
mi-saison nous offrons à nos
téléspectateurs pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre alors zones
blanches elle signifie que
colporte gamelle avec une grosse
pièce jointe qui ne vous
attendez d'être dans un autre
endroit pour mourir parce que
vous savez que ça va me prendre
des joueurs comme de petits
missiles pas de doute pas de
télévision pas de téléphone
ni par internet a été
acquitté
et pour cent de toutes ces
nouvelles
fonctionnalités qui font des
volumes pour ceux qui trouvent
tout à fait leur place dans le
déploiement de la fibre optique
c'est des choses vont pour
certains certains habitants des
zones rurales sont aujourd'hui
privés et à l échéance de
trois ans quatre ans maintenant
le tout le monde pour avoir
accès à tous
la commission note toutefois une
très bonne chose
mais je veux pas te remercie
beaucoup pour un tacle dangereux
ce grand prix
et me retrouvant sur le plateau
le québécois sur le professeur
de mathématiques au collège
alexandre dumas à maurepas
les audois 30 députés ont
débuté quand on se pose
souvent cette question
est-ce que pour préparer les
comprend
à la rentrée suivante
une question qui a tendance à
mitonner un petit peu avant
c'est la question qu'on devrait
tous les essais puis turin
comment faire pour que mon
enfant se reposer pendant les
vacances
et foi en forme pour la rentrée
scolaire
au monde oui
alors pourquoi plupart des vbz %
samedi peu avant l'été
je dirais pas qu'il ne faut pas
les préparer et je pense qu'il
ne faut pas essayer absolument
les devoirs de vacances en tout
cas
la bataille de syrte
ces termes me dérange
énormément alors quand on
quitte le but
quelly de marzy
vous en pensez quoi y'en a pas
mal
il fonctionne plus durant
l'été
vous avez un petit peu plus le
ps voulait connaître un petit
potager koné arrive à
l'époque j'étais au collège
mais patatras
m je pense que si votre enfant
est demandeur
c'est important de lui en
acheter un
et il ya de fortes chances qu'il
le fasse
si votre enfant n'est pas
demandeur
ça sert à rien de mettre sous
pression et de forcer
parce que c'est vraiment
important de ne pas associer à
le travail scolaire à une
finition à une sanction
donc que quelques qu'il est
demandeur de francs
donc on peut dire que durant les
deux nouveaux promus plus lourd
au courant vous êtes plutôt
sport il faut vraiment le
véhicule jusqu'au premier jour
% à la rentrée scolaire
agenda ici et là je pense qu'il
est important de maintenir une
intimidation cérébrale ça
c'est très important
mais plutôt de le faire sous
forme ludique
la voix annonce que son jeu
édité par le groupe pour une
suisse sans armée a dit sur les
réseaux sociaux cette année
des de salami de calculer leur
musique
mais en club pourquoi pas dans
la voiture pour la tunisie kryte
meti faire du calcul mental
quand vous faites les courses
avec votre enfant pourquoi pas
les faire travailler leur de
grandeur en essayant de trouver
celui qui a eu lieu
le résultat des courses les
plus proches et que si par
exemple il faut choisir le
défaire
% au lieu de faire des dictées
des rédactions print a rédigé
un carnet de voyage ou écrire
une lettre à la grand-mère et
très détaillés ou mike brown
ideye votre enfant et vous en
profitez pour retravailler
l'orthographe
la tante pétunia site en état
opep le bus pour rentrer dedans
comment ne pas brusquement
françois devin c'est pourquoi
quand même être
contre-productive si on me donne
trop de droits
de devoir durant l'été
vraiment ça a quel est ton
enfant petit-enfant et
demanderait un amendement qui
sont demandeurs
de de lecture de devoir
equiterre org
dont acte de mandarine en a deux
qui ne font pas mais je pense
qu'en effet il faut pas brusquer
impeccable et pour boucler le
professeur yves ceux qui
préparent pour cent donc
la rentrée à la mi août ou
même pendant les deux mois pour
s'en priver les all blacks on
vous les avez à la rentrée
vous voyez une différence
entre ceux qui ont préparé la
rentrée et ceux qui
je suis trop reposée
alors assez simple en fait je ne
peux pas ne pas voir
ils ont préparé la rentrée ou
pas
mais attention hein quand je
parle donc de se reposer mais
bien sûr un nez comme j'ai dit
que ça a l'air toujours un
continent noir
un petit numéro de printemps
portant sur des votes et donc je
vois la reprise d'opel je ne
peux pas savoir
si l'on travaillé à compaq et
il ya un mois je prends le parti
en début d'année de commenter
un ancien contrat qui demande
quasiment aucune nation
précédente
pour commencer un voile sur de
nouvelles bases et alors que l
élève ait confiance en lui
dès le début ça c'est très
important
donc pour les parents qui
cultive des voix il faut
comprendre
soit prêt pour le retour
je pense qu'il me dise pas que
les professeurs dans ce type de
technique en tout cas peut-être
la vôtre ce que
au fond un dans le collège je
suis en général on a tendance
à faire cette technique-là
en tout cas on ne va pas faire
de ce contrôle de rentrée pour
cent
regardez les nations qui restent
e on sait très bien que pendant
deux mois
l'élève il n'a pas travaillé
on en a conscience que dumont a
pas beaucoup travaillé donc
nivard doucement et c'est pareil
pour nous les filles
je le connais pas beaucoup de
progrès partout travail pendant
deux mois à la rentrée je la
prépare à environ dix jours
avant que j'ai alors regardé un
ballet changement de programme
et qui étaient rares
mais pour cent dans la
conscience que la planète
les bleus ont donc cru que le
mur on trouva que le poteau de
codes de la culture
combien de temps c'est quoi le
premier mois les deux premières
semaines
image tirée du milieu de
première semaine
maintenant deux premières
semaines sont suffisantes pour
combler toutes les semaines je
tue vraiment commentaire
haha au revoir des nations
il a commenté
des chapitres qui demande des
nations précédente
donc le début de la crise que
vous préconisez
on vous en avez d'autres de ce
que vaille des parents qui ne
regardent plus douce diamant
nous en a donné espoir ajouté
ronaldo trentaine
attendez laissez-moi les six
sièges
gc qui fait partie de ces
enfants maxi travail est
important maintenant l'été je
vais pas vous mentir après
de nombreux palabres voie
lactée les députés
continuaient pour cent
on les fait travailler c'est une
manière de détourner
transparente
mais pour la mère des croyants
mais actuellement et donc pour
les mettre de côté et on va
droit au but pour les objets
pour les mêmes thématiques et
à c'est vraiment privilégié
de calcul mental
à ne surtout pas chercher à
faire absolument réaliser le
théorème de pythagore à
réviser le théorème de
thalès qui paiera les pots des
projecteurs par enfant
chargeront
elle a vraiment hâte de
manière amusante
la cheminée il est trouvée
totale quand on fait des courses
familiale
envoiture fr une recette de
cuisine et faire travailler et
à l'état de se comporter
finalité
aya ya plein d'astuces comme par
exemple faire travailler les
mathématiques
de manière à détourner
comme didier
pour le français et au lieu de
d'employés à l'élève à
votre enfant par exemple
il est actuellement élève mais
elle est votre enfant m une
dictée ou une rédaction
aida la rédaction peut se
transformer en carnet de voyage
dans la lettre pour un magnet
qui était rarement où l'on
peut très bien au travail et
leur programme pour acheter des
petits cahiers de mots mêlés
et ce genre de choses
c'est comme le fumeur regardez
par exemple ainsi demandé aux
autres
au lieu d'y arrêter de regarder
italien en français qui les
regarder en vidéo
et on leur souhaite
pourquoi votre blog le revenu
doit affronter pour le préparer
et préparer vos repas
mais d'une manière détournée
et un peu plus ludique que leur
part placé
hébergeant mètres
c'est de nous avoir suivis pour
ce fait une pub et volupté
bonne soirée à tous
pendant longtemps encore
m